don't get attached on your face and get
sober you know I'm saying I don't know
you the younger generation is doing that
it's not that young
yeah [ __ ] like little easy oh this is
the last time people gonna be used in
our faces we're gonna be like the last
generation of people that like had faces
with no tat like it's gonna get it's
starting to become regular you know
what's her name Rosa um oh my god
thug Rosa [ __ ] what's her drug ROS
thugs wrote no Rose rose mcgowan no
Amber Rose Amber Rose who's dating a
Queen Latifah was drugged rose they call
her the nickname yeah she got famous
from Kanye she was a stripper got
finished from Kanye she got a tattoo on
her face Tachi [ __ ] his Shia LeBouf or
someone yeah hash and mozi are slash and
back slash bash she's so pretty why the
[ __ ] would you do it to your face man
but that's what I'm saying bro it's it's
getting to where this is the end of
people use their like regular skin we're
gonna have different it's gonna be
something else in the future you got to
think about that Brennan you can't be
milling around not thinking she was so
such you so sexy man
Kanye she's such a bad I don't know I
didn't see it what did you guys think
culture I don't know I I don't know I'm
not attracted to her why she's huge tits
and a fan that's what it is and what a
raised deserter bright Ray's deserting
know that she's sexy Wow I mean that's a
bad pay come on Nick do me a favor yeah
okay come on bro oh that one what are we
doing man
yes she looks like a dude that played
Center for our basketball team when I
was 12
well your Center had the biggest tits
tell the holler at me yeah he really did
he was raised by his grandparents his
boy Tommy hmm Wow doesn't that she does
look brave but she does look nice right
there that's interesting
she a beautiful lady she got the
children slashing bass Jude you know and
they're / yeah and there's slash
embarrassment that's why she named
probably yeah and the baby daddy is uh
Wiz Khalifa Wow hmm what do you guys
think chin she's I think she's
attractive but she's just too much for
me yeah thick yeah there's too much too
much for ya
and that's one of the reasons I think if
you really if you like the acid ain't
for you yeah yeah you can't be just that
little uh give me that little chihuahua
humping a leg you feel me - yeah you
can't look like Jesse Lockwood out here
you'll be that Rottweiler bad boy you
know that dick game day you feel yeah I
think that's why a lot of black men have
long wieners because they gotta you
gotta get in there you got to drink that
milkshake but you can't you know you
can't be [ __ ] shooting three-pointers
all day with a white wiener on a black
woman you can't brother
do the math daddy do the body math son
see that's the realest thing you've ever
said dude it's real real dude he just
broke it down you can't get in the game
if you don't you got the [ __ ] right
Pole yeah whole vault with that little
stuff yeah you can't be out there -
shooting darts you know yeah that's why
man that's genetics as biology daddy
that's why they do it has body mass so
on that nightstick
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]